this fall watch one man attempt the
impossible
running backs aren't an optimal position
anymore i'm going to break the rushing
record record but you have one more game
than eric dickerson it'll have an
asterix my whole career is at an
asterisk
derek henry can never be a professional
running back he's far too big and strong
derek stop stiff farming you're scaring
the other children at the university of
alabama watch him buck the projections
look we come from a long line of oilers
that's all we'll ever be so just hide
the fact that you're 6'3 240 pounds be a
normal back and inspire us wait wha what
what's this it's a tweet from adam
schefter titan's rb derek henry suffered
a potentially seasonal ending oh no okay
derek's hurt oh no what the hell derek
basically the whole team what are you
doing i'm sorry i'm trying to farm like
derek but it's hard poor also has it now
it's real sorry family only can't you
see i'm his brother oh no no no no very
clearly not hey uh the story of uh ryan
you want to win so bad when i'm gonna
try to win good we are in total
agreement you watching derek's high
school tape no this was derek playing
this year's buffalo bills critics are
calling it definitely not great an
inspiring story if it somehow works out
and finally a victory for pass first
analytics
with saquon barkley you want to know
what the best part of my day is
driving up to the giants facility and
hoping no one is there naji harris naji
we're tripling your production
when i'm a rookie whoever's playing
running back for the ravens
and introducing cordero patterson i'm a
receiver basket using the views and
cordaro patterson i'm a running back we
can play into our 30s now watch tana
hill become a tandem mountain they say
he could only be out for like six weeks
[Music]
gridiron heights presents
remember the titan out now and out
indefinitely any other division would be
done so thank god for you guys oh yeah
yeah you got this my lawyers advised me
not to say anything
[Music]
and from the makers of remember the
titan
comes the story of the ragtag cleveland
browns in
the breakfast chub
yeah sorry it's just me we're all taking
turns being hurt